the final sunday of summer
and the final regular season home game
at wrigley field the twins are in town
their first series at wrigley since 2018
when they were swept here
on a very hot weekend in chicago or the
setting is much
different in 2020 with no fans however
with two teams who appear confident in
their post-season
chances you darvish with his
next-to-last regular season chance to
pad that cy young resume
you darvish's third year with the cubs
he has had a breakthrough with a 1.86
era
and an opportunity now for the number
three batter eddie rosario
and rosario bounces it through the right
side
that's going to wrap around kepler to
score and the twins have scored before
they have put it out on the board
tonight
to me that's a base hit that's a nasty
hop and a big opportunity now for miguel
sano
got him swinging first track out of the
night for darvers this is the change
split here
and 93 miles an hour good sink on that
ball
only one out recorded and now it's the
switch hitting shortstop jorge polanco
got him swinging and his 26th pitch
maddie's
best so far is the curveball the wicket
curveball
and here's mitch garver now out of the
jam with
only a single score and it is jose
barrios on the mound for the twins 26
year old right hander four and three on
the season
coming off a no decision his last time
on the mound against the white sox
here's anthony rizzo now with one god
not anymore a bunt attempt carrillos
gets on it nicely
well played as rizzo tried the sneak
attack
burritos looking more like javi bias
here like a cat off the mound
shore stop like actions oh my too easy
one nothing twins second inning jake
cave the batter
stroke toward left field long run
schwarber toward the line can't get it
over his head one hop against the vines
jk of a hustling three-base hit to the
opposite corner and left
the ball bounces into the ivy cal
schwarber kind of goes in and gets it
the move for kyle schwarber being taken
out of the game is there a health update
you have to pass along on him
no no no he's fine he's fine
so a manager's decision got it and
here's kepler who started the trouble
with the lead off single
[Applause]
on the ground to the drawn in kipnis
it's going to score the run
because jason had to tumble to make that
play and it's two nothing minnesota
so no wade and polanco here in the third
and a three pitch strikeout
a couple of strikeouts into one two
three third by u darvish still
two-nothing minnesota
and a man aboard for ian happ
and a swing and a miss first strike out
of the game for jose
barrios one away second and third with
one gone for chris bryant who's singled
in the first
got him and the challenge continues for
bryant on the nasty breaking ball
javi baya digging in against his
brother-in-law we mentioned earlier that
javi and and jose are married to sisters
this is the first time that they will
have met
head-to-head on the first pitch a ground
ball to third donaldson comes home and
the tags applied at the plate
contreras is out trying to score
brown bought a third donaldson picks it
up plays cash with the catcher
i mean he's out right there one out one
on here for eddie rosario
rosario lines to hayward who might have
lost that in the lights
great recovery by the five-time gold
glover
with two out and runner aboard now from
miguel cino
i miss him darvish gets him again the
strikeout strands are runners we
continue to the bottom of the fifth
inning still two-nothing minnesota
is trying to have a quick one two three
six in him
in good shape right now he's mowing him
down and the pitch it's a swing and a
miss boy
over mats contreras brios now has
retired
six in a row lead off hitter in scoring
position
oh and max kepler sends a ball well hit
out to right
and gone two run homer for max kepler
four nothing minnesota the happy zone
down and into a left-hander all you got
to do is drop the hammer
[Music]
1-2 pitch to victor carratini's popped
up trevor may picking up right where
jose barrios left off with a
two three seven ten in a row retired by
twins pitching
trevor may with a perfect seventh
and now rogers with his second strikeout
of the inning
so nico horner will make his first
played appearance of the night
and he'll do so as the potential tying
run
the next one too did he check it
he went around and that's going to do it
sergio romo weathers a bases loaded
threat
to wrap up a four nothing twins win in
chicago